Bradley Cooper you are hot Sandra oh and
Andy Samberg co-hosted the 76th Golden
Globe Awards on Sunday night and kicked
off their hilarious monologue by
viciously roasting the audience with
compliments hey Jeff I wish you were my
dad highlights included calling out Lady
Gaga's infamous quote there can be a
hundred people in the room and 99 don't
believe in you and you just need one to
believe in you and that was Bradley
Cooper a quote she even told et Bradley
is an a visionary human being he has
such an eye for creating an atmosphere
of liberation and talent and he he
believed in me you know a hundred people
can be in a room and 99 don't believe in
you and just one person believes in you
and it can change everything and he
believed in me and I I am I'm so
grateful to him for that Jim Carrey got
kicked out of the movie section and used
his moment to plug Sonic the Hedgehog
it's called Sonic the Hedgehog comes out
in November oh well you know come back
next year I'm sure we'll be nominated
if you listen closely you will hear Emma
Stone Hill out I'm sorry for Aloha
take a listen it is the first studio
film with an Asian American lead since
ghosts in the shell in Aloha
but most importantly Sandro is a
powerful speech about change I wanted to
be here to look out into this audience
and witness this moment of change and I
see you all these faces of change and
now so will everyone else ET spoke with
the host other co-stars ahead of their
gig on the red carpet Sandra is killing
Eve castmates have you talked to Sandra
is she ready how she feeling as she was
she rehearsing when you guys were
together or what anything like that
she's as cool of the cucumber she's I
mean she says she's very very nervous
but she's the most professional person
I've ever met my life so I just know
she's gonna smash this way she's gonna
ace it and Andy's Brooklyn nine-nine pal
Terry Crews
andis up here today did you give him any
hints any tips on hosting you know what
I told him I literally sang I was like
we ready we know I literally did that he
was like I'm pumped I tried to tell him
just relax man you got this do your
thing do what you do Andy Samberg
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]